el que lo dice lo es esa ha sido la
respuesta de vladimir putin ante las
declaraciones de iovine al que por
cierto ha deseado buena salud en su
primera reacción tras las duras
declaraciones del presidente
norteamericano que llamó asesinó al
líder ruso
el kremlin también ha condenado las
declaraciones de job háyder sobre
vladimir putin moscú dice que ya da por
sentado que el mandatario estadounidense
no tiene ninguna intención de normalizar
las relaciones con rusia tras las
palabras de bailén y como primer gesto
de protesta rusia llamó a consultas a
moscú a su embajador en eeuu
anatoli antónov pasado mañana el
embajador ruso ya estará aquí en moscú y
en momento sin billete de vuelta para
regresar a washington la tensión entre
ambos países ya aumento a principios de
esta semana cuando el consejo de
inteligencia nacional de eeuu hizo
público un informe en el que acusaba al
gobierno ruso de tratar de perjudicar a
bailén en las elecciones presidenciales
de 2020 y de paso mirar la confianza del
pueblo estadounidense en el proceso
electoral